- I mentioned British hip-hop before,
I love rap music, that's,
it's one of the reasons
I live in America, I think
that it's the best place
for my rap career.
You're laughing, it's true!
I love rapping, I really do,
and I love freestyle rap,
that's rap that you make up on the spot.
- Do it!
- Well, obviously,
it would be so weird for me to bring it up
and then not do it?
I love that some people don't understand
how entertainment works, like.
It's like, if I walked
out, I was like, my penis
is entirely tattooed,
and then never showed you
my tattooed penis?
You're like, it's weird
that he mentioned that.
I wanna clarify, don't feel
like that, it's not, it's not.
And I'm not gonna prove that.
But I will rap, but I, what I need to know
is what you'd like the
rap to be about, so,
wait, wait, one second,
one sec, please, there are,
I know that rap is very
unruly, but British rap,
there are rules.
You listen and then we take
it in turns to suggest.
So you're all gonna come
up with what you want
a rap about, we need five
suggestions in total,
they should be words, topics, or phrases,
they shouldn't be food,
they shouldn't be animals,
and they shouldn't be
too boring or obvious,
and I will tell you if I find them boring,
it's not 'cause I don't
wanna rap about it,
it's 'cause we can do better.
So, suggestions like a day in the life
of an Aztec high priest, or, yeah.
Yeah, so, let's come
to this segment first,
what would you like a rap about?
- Astronauts!
- Was that astronaut
or astro-nun?
Astronaut, okay, well, what about,
what is it about astronauts
that intrigue you?
- Going to space?
- Well, obviously,
that's in the job description.
Yeah, what would you, tell
me what this astronaut
is doing in space.
- I don't know.
- I'm aware that, really,
I'm pushing it further
than you wish to go, someone else?
Someone else can help,
just give me an activity?
- Space walks!
- What did you say?
- Untethered space walks, oh!
That's, those are dangerous, yeah?
Yeah, you're still touching your chin.
An astronaut on an untethered
space walk, I like it.
Let's come to this side of the room,
this is where someone said "rap"!
- Coronavirus!
- Um, I mean, it's been,
you know, like, 15-plus months
and so I've rapped about that
already and I don't like to
do the same suggestion twice,
so I will ask for a
different, better suggestion.
- British colonization!
- You said British colonization
and you said threesomes, okay.
I mean, one is more interesting, isn't it?
And one I know quite a lot about, but.
Okay, so British
colonization and threesomes.
Astronauts, untethered space walks,
middle front of the room, what
would you like a rap about?
- Dinosaur's last day on earth?
- You said, well that's
incorporated in that,
the dinosaur's last
day on Earth, you said?
- Arsenal football club.
- Arsenal football club, okay,
that's a name of a
pretty, let's be honest,
mid-table team now.
And the dinosaur's last day on Earth,
maybe Arsenal, I just feel
like that would go over
the heads of a lot of people.
And back of the room,
what would you like a rap about?
- Hakuna matata!
- Hakuna matata,
what a wonderful phrase.
Okay, so the suggestions are astronauts
on an untethered space
walk, British colonization,
threesomes, dinosaurs last
day on Earth, perhaps Arsenal,
and Hakuna matata, so it's
gonna be a little rap.
Last night, it was a slightly
slower beat than usual,
I know we've used that beat
but could we make it just
like, maybe five BPM faster
tonight, is that okay?
Yeah, that'd be...
Jesus fucking Christ, that feels like a,
feels like a gauntlet's been thrown down.
So, a freestyle, it's
made up, it's not written,
it's not prepared, it's not rehearsed,
dinosaurs' last day on earth,
space walk, hakuna matata,
threesomes and colonization,
this is fuckin' funky,
this is different as well,
Red's smiling at me like
yeah I'm gonna fuck you up, Chris, okay.
Cool, nice.
Cool, let's do it, nice.
♪ Trouble fire I'm into you ♪
♪ I've got the company I'm
bringing it out to East India ♪
♪ I've got a large ship,
we travel from a nation ♪
♪ Or the natives they be
like, oh shit, colonization ♪
♪ From the Brit pack ♪
♪ They've got the queen on the flag ♪
♪ I know in hindsight it seems real bad ♪
♪ And at the time they were like, no ♪
♪ We're civilizing, all the
natives, have some tea ♪
♪ When we're arriving, we're surprising ♪
♪ Then we've got the
muskets and the daggers ♪
♪ We're going to arrive ♪
♪ Yes you wish that
you had had a lookout ♪
♪ To tell us to go away
and you're hoping some ♪
♪ Welcome to China, we'll
be dealing you the opium ♪
♪ It's what we really do,
we're giving it for sure ♪
♪ Got the provinces and
princes over there in India ♪
♪ And they adore that we gave
them cricket and trains ♪
♪ But admittedly their
culture was forever changed ♪
♪ With the shit that we
did, I'm not praising ♪
♪ And I'm not saying it's
amazing, got my little astronaut ♪
♪ That I'm displaying, I'll be
changing all the solar panels ♪
♪ On the space station, Sandra
Bullock, George Clooney, ♪
♪ They be hatin', like,
don't worry Sandra, ♪
♪ I'm feeling clever let me
go out of the door, airlock, ♪
♪ Untethered, there's no need for a rope ♪
♪ No need for a chain,
I'm gonna go out there ♪
♪ Oh, fuck there's flames
all around me, exploding ♪
♪ And flowing past Mars,
past Venus, past Jupiter ♪
♪ Wait, let's pause and say,
Mars, then Venus, then Jupiter ♪
♪ That's a weird path ♪
♪ If you are a scientist, yeah
you would understand that ♪
♪ One problem that you can't avoid ♪
♪ Back in the day 65
million years an asteroid ♪
♪ Coming down if you know
the name like this dude ♪
♪ What's the name of the asteroid ♪
♪ Chicxulub ♪
♪ Caused a crater right near Yucatan ♪
♪ The dinosaurs were living there ♪
♪ They had grazing on the sand ♪
♪ With the T-rexs or
brontosaurii or triceratops ♪
♪ They're like, we love bein' dinosaurs ♪
♪ I hope it never stops ♪
♪ But it did, they fucking wiped out ♪
♪ It's ever so sad,
yeah, get out the house ♪
♪ I get to fuckin' Highbury,
now it's called the Emirates ♪
♪ It's Arsenal Stadium, I
know it sounds pathetic ♪
♪ You'd be like, Chris,
this sport's not simple ♪
♪ 2004 weren't they calling
them the invincibles ♪
♪ Undefeated, I'll share with ya ♪
♪ The team was great on
William Patrick V Era ♪
♪ But now they've got Mikel Arteta ♪
♪ Need to finish much better ♪
♪ And they can't ask, no, you're
really gosh damn pathetic ♪
♪ It's a shame though, they
wear the white and the red ♪
♪ Again, all of this part of
the rap goes over their heads ♪
♪ It's real fun ♪
♪ And it doesn't even matter ♪
♪ A freestyle rapper like Hakuna matata ♪
♪ A wonderful phrase, yeah,
I'm gonna thumb there ♪
♪ A lift, got my man Timon and Pumba ♪
♪ It's me, my name's
Simba, a tiny little lion ♪
♪ Nala, she abandoned me
and left this lion cryin' ♪
♪ Why, 'cause Jeremy
Irons, the voice of Scar ♪
♪ Was there in the stampede
like, I killed your dad ♪
♪ He be down there,
Papa, lying in the dirt ♪
♪ It means it's gonna be fine,
there's no need to hurt ♪
♪ And these three guys
on the Disney screen ♪
♪ I'm like, these guys, they're amazing ♪
♪ But in my dream I see
Simon, Timba, and Pumba ♪
♪ They were getting down kind
of weird by the bums there ♪
♪ I was saying, shit, this
is not the PG I'm seeing ♪
♪ A Disney Lion King
threesome, that's obscene ♪
♪ It's the worst thing that
you've ever ever ever seen ♪
♪ That's why they didn't
make a Lion King Three ♪
♪ It would have gone down, it
would have been struck off ♪
♪ There we go, freestyle
rap, but no mic drop ♪
(chill hip-hop beat)
(audience cheering and applauding)
Thank you, you guys are nice, bye-bye!